a slap heard around the world a criminal
rampage through paradise and one actor
who took method acting way too far what
more jaw-dropping things could fans of
beloved actors do
will smith made the wrong kind of
history at the 94th academy awards when
chris rock made a joke about jada
pinkett smith will smith walked on stage
during his monologue and slapped him
across the face in the immediate
aftermath many thought the incident was
a pre-arranged gag but after smith
yelled profanities twice from his seat
it became clear there was nothing staged
about it while many fans supported smith
others criticized him a number of
celebrities began to speak out
particularly those in the comedy world
who were anything but sympathetic
towards him it was
a most disturbing
incident for sure it was an assault when
the smoke cleared smith was hit with a
decade-long ban from any and all academy
awards events including the oscars but
it isn't just in terms of awards that
will smith is being punished since the
slap development on a number of smith
projects has either been delayed or
outright cancelled for example work on
the planned fourth film of the bad boys
franchise has been paused while
netflix's bright too has been scrapped
completely
in february 2021 gina carano was fired
from her signature role of cara dune on
the mandalorian in an instagram post
that has since been deleted carano
compared to those who criticized her
political views to nazis that was the
final straw for disney and lucasfilm who
were reportedly already incensed with
carano after two controversial november
2020 tweets one tweet from carano
implied that president joe biden had
committed voter fraud and the other
mocked people wearing masks during the
coven 19 pandemic carano has continued
to double down on the same kind of
social media posts that got her booted
from star wars one such tweet posted not
long after the one year anniversary of
her firing peddled a conspiracy theory
that the united states government
orchestrated russia's invasion of
ukraine because it quote lost control of
the covid narrative while carano
continues to find work thanks to ben
shapiro's production company it's
probably safe to say that she won't be
turning up in star wars anytime soon
from a certain point of view mel gibson
seems to be the luckiest actor alive in
2020 he starred as the villain opposite
frank grillo in hulu's boss level and
he'll reportedly be stepping into the
late richard donner's shoes to both
direct and star in lethal weapon 5.
along with other upcoming projects he
landed a role for the upcoming john wick
prequel series the continental and yet
gibson's continuing career seems to
single-handedly disprove the existence
of so-called cancel culture in 2006
gibson was pulled over for alleged drunk
driving and let loose an anti-semitic
rant on the officers the oscar-winning
director and actor was already persona
non-grata to many after depicting the
glee of jewish characters over the death
of jesus in 2004's the passion of the
christ four years later audio tapes
leaked of threatening and racist
statements the actor made to
ex-girlfriend oksana rigo riva and in
2011 he pleaded no contest to domestic
abuse charges against her despite many
former fans swearing off gibson forever
the guy just keeps on getting work
in 2018 a revival of the long dormant
sitcom roseanne enjoyed unprecedented
success with most of the original cast
returning for a 10th season the titular
lead roseanne barr hadn't been much of a
presence on television ever since the
series first closed up shop in 1997. all
she had to do to remain on top was avoid
tweeting a racist joke about former
presidential advisor valerie jarrett but
apparently that was too much to ask
i thought the [ __ ] was white
damn it
i thought that was white
in may 2018 the offending tweet ended
roseanne for good barr apologized to
jarrett tried blaming the tweet on
ambien tweeting and eventually announced
she was leaving twitter but it was too
little too late first fellow actress and
comic wanda sykes announced she would
not return to her consulting producer
job on roseanne and soon afterwards abc
fired barr and canceled the show
altogether later that year the connors
premiered minus barr with the revelation
that her character had died of an opiate
overdose in a guest column for thr
showrunner bruce haldeford wrote that
the decision was made to kill her
character off to make her departure
clearly permanent
to some it might seem like a surprise
that it took the public so long to turn
on ezra miller in april 2020 during a
time when so much as a single poorly
conceived tweet could end a career a
video surfaced of what appeared to be
miller choking a woman and throwing her
to the ground yet somehow the usual
cancel culture campaigns remained silent
as did miller fans had a harder time
ignoring it when miller was arrested in
hilo hawaii in march 2022 they were
charged with disorderly conduct and
harassment after allegedly yelling
obscenities at patrons in a karaoke bar
they also allegedly grabbed a microphone
out of a woman's hand and lunged at a
man playing darts and things only got
worse from there a couple in hilo have
filed a temporary restraining order
against hollywood actor ezra miller
after miller allegedly barged into their
bedroom
not long after miller was released on
bail a couple that miller was reportedly
staying with filed a restraining order
against miller accusing them of
threatening the couple and stealing some
of their belongings only a few weeks
later miller was arrested yet again this
time in pahoa hawaii they had reportedly
been asked to leave a party and in
response allegedly threw a chair that
struck a woman in the head shortly after
the first arrest rumors began swirling
that warner brothers were considering
kicking their flash in fantastic beasts
star to the curb at the same time the
controversy has had many fans calling
for miller to be replaced by grant
gustin as the dceu's flash if that
wasn't enough in june 2022 parents of an
18 year old activist sought out court
intervention against miller for grooming
their daughter as rolling stone reported
just a few weeks later miller was
hosting a 25 year old mother and her
three young children at a secluded farm
in vermont where the children were
reportedly found with easy access to
guns bullets and marijuana lying around
the house
in the late 2010s scarlett johansson
became the face of privileged
celebrities taking roles that should
have gone to actors from other
communities the first example was when
she agreed to the lead role of the
cybernetically enhanced major mira
kilian in 2017's ghost in the shell the
thing is in the source material and the
anime adaptations the character's name
was motoko kusanagi by accepting the
role of a traditionally japanese
character johansson joined the long and
regretful tradition of hollywood
whitewashing she courted controversy the
following year when she agreed to play a
transgender man in rob and tug after
critics argued that the role should go
to a transgender man johansson issued a
brief statement to bustle referencing
other actors who have played trans
characters that said tell them that they
can be directed to jeffrey tambor jared
leto and felicity hoffman's reps for
comment johansen later apologized for
the statement and quit rub and tug but
with the controversy coming so hard on
the heels of ghost in the shell it may
be a while before people forget about
this
jared leto's method acting already
became somewhat legendary after behind
the scenes story surfaced from the
production of 2016's suicide squad
including reports of the actor
apparently sending a dead hog to the
cast as a twisted present but while the
suicide squad stories were just weird
something arguably more offensive
happened on the set of the long delayed
morbius in an april 2022 interview with
uprocks morbius director daniel espinosa
confirmed that leto pretended to be
disabled like his character in between
takes he used a set of crutches to get
himself to and from bathroom breaks for
example until that took too long and it
was decided crew members would bring him
back and forth in a wheelchair and
that's when i fell in love with vampires
the story has done nothing to help
letto's reputation along with drawing
out accusations of ableism the story
prompted other actors to take indirect
pot shots at leto though he didn't
mention leto by name while promoting
fantastic beasts the secrets of
dumbledore mass mikkelsen called method
acting quote pretentious not long after
john bernthal voiced his opinion on
method acting saying he saw no benefit
in taking it to such extremes
in january 2019 former empire star jesse
smollette announced that he had been the
victim of a hate crime in january 2019
the actor claimed that two men attacked
him poured an unknown substance on him
and put a noose around his neck in a
racially motivated attack but by the
following month the chicago pd had
become convinced that the incident was
staged it seemed that smollett had hired
the nigerian brothers ola binjo and
abimbola osandero to stage the attack as
a bid to negotiate a higher rate on
empire
smollett was arrested and charged with
disorderly conduct and filing a false
police report as more and more evidence
came out the same fans and celebrities
who initially showered smilet with
support showed him nothing but disdain
smollett's first trial was dismissed but
he was still let go from empire and new
charges were brought against him in
2020. in late december 2021 smilet was
found guilty on 5 out of 6 charges of
disorderly conduct the actor was ordered
to spend 150 days in jail spend 30
months on probation and pay a fine of
145 000
while he got off light all things
considered it's doubtful you'll be
seeing his imdb page getting any new
additions anytime soon
dave chappelle caught flack for a while
for making jokes considered transphobic
but he took special aim at the subject
in his 2021 netflix special the closer
among other things the comic proudly
called himself a turf a term for
feminists who don't consider trans women
to be women he also invoked his late
friend daphne dorman a trans woman who
died by suicide in a way that many found
offensive and i don't know what the
trans community did for her but i don't
care because i feel like she wasn't
their tribe
she was mine she was a comedian in her
soul after the special aired ajo romano
wrote for vox that chappelle makes it
clear that he needs dorman to exist on
his terms not hers not as a trans woman
with autonomy but as a trans woman who's
proven she deserves autonomy by way of
having a chill laid-back sense of humor
in other words chappelle's acceptance of
dorman as a trans woman was conditional
the same month the closer began
streaming on netflix a group of netflix
employees staged a walkout protesting
both chappelle's special on the platform
and what they saw as an unhealthy work
environment chappelle will still
apparently host and produce more comedy
specials for netflix in the future but
to many fans the comic died on stage in
2021
what do you remember most from
terminator salvation well if you were
paying any attention to entertainment
news in 2009 then it's probably the
infamous audio recording that leaked a
few months before the film's release
that year tmz posted a recording of
christian bale who played john connor in
the film ranting for just under four
minutes at director of photography shane
hurlbut dropping more f-bombs then even
skynet could coordinate bail accused
hurlbut of distracting him during
filming by walking aimlessly around the
set you can hear hurlbut apologizing
throughout the recording and other crew
members trying to calm bell down but to
no avail bale apologized for the rant
after the audio surfaced and ensured
fans that he and herbert worked out
their differences before the day was
through still bale has never been able
to completely shake the reputation he
earned when his tirade went public
in the wake of jeopardy host alex
trebek's passing the question of who
could succeed him proved much more
controversial than most anticipated
sitcom actor mayan bialik was chosen to
share co-hosting duties with former
jeopardy champ ken jennings but in the
case of bialik a controversial past
followed her to the show in 2017 bialik
had written what proved to be an
extremely divisive op-ed in the new york
times about harvey weinstein she
suggested that like her women should
dress modestly and not act flirtatiously
something many took as victim shaming
the alec has also expressed fringe views
about vaccinations for years although
she says she's vaccinated against
covid19 as well as these larger issues
jeopardy fans continued to yell bloody
murder at much smaller offenses from
bialik while hosting the show the
offenses she's gathered while hosting
the game show include using the term
single jeopardy and wearing the same
orange knit blazer more than once
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you